yeah  me and my wife went to the uh the  Sistine Chapel okay so we're in that  thing you know it's boring as [ __ ] right  it says Dean Chapel it's boring if you  take the long route where there's all  the broken bites I [ __ ] spoon every  Pope [ __ ] you know had his cereal  with I mean it's just I I don't give a  [ __ ] about old dishes I I don't remember  that part of it you can avoid it and we  [ __ ] up and we went the long [ __ ]  everybody's [ __ ] James Brown robe  that did mass or whatever we get all the  way out there  like shut the [ __ ] up so I'm standing  I'm looking at it and you know it was  nice he said do I go you know if I lived  here  I would open a bar across the street  called the 17 Chapel and she was like  what  yeah I got the 16th chapel oh 17. that's  when she looked at me it's the Sistine  oh Lord is that like a manly thing to  know like you got to know it's not a  manly thing to know it's just a thing to  know the Sistine Chapel is fairly famous